we have this from timcast.com second New
Jersey Republican elected official shot
and killed within a week authorities
have not identified a motive but
confirmed the victim was the intended
target this is Milford Borough
councilman Russell Heller was murdered
by a co-worker at a PS Eng facility so
we don't know exactly why maybe it's not
political perhaps but we also had Eunice
dwemfer who was shot to death in a
vehicle outside her home and when asked
if this was political the D.A said that
they didn't uh you know they said
something along uh to the effect of you
know please don't make you know we don't
want to answer that right now or
something something like that so I I
don't know if this is political
but uh we certainly are seeing extremist
rhetoric we just had a bunch of leftist
storm into a capitol building oh
Insurrection or whatever and uh in the
previous segment we were talking about
uh Reed you were mentioning that it's
easier to drum up opposition to uh right
like legitimate opposition to Joe Biden
to get in Republican or libertarian
policies because you have you know that
the president and it would be a lot more
difficult under Trump but I guess
looking at this I kind of feel like even
with a President Joe Biden the media is
still screaming the right is the Deep
threat you still have I mean is it a
coincidence that two Republican elected
officials were just shot and killed in
New Jersey in one week
maybe
um is it political it might not be I'm
kind of leaning towards two Republican
officials being shot and killed in the
span of a week I'd at least lean towards
the hypothesis we should look into
whether this is political considering
the rhetoric from the media and
everything like that so if we've got a
democrat in office shouldn't shouldn't
things be calming down at least as far
as the leftist rhetoric is it's it's
more hyped up and amped up than ever
yeah well I think the evolutionaries
that we have to worry about I think the
hyped up rhetoric is what causes a lot
of the right-wing opposition to the
Democrats at church so for example like
people who didn't pay attention to
politics at all four years ago after the
last two years when they're suddenly a
science denying uh you know conspiracy
theorist or whatever and they're an
enemy of intelligence agencies or
whatever suddenly they start to care
about FBI the the FBI having as much
power as it does they start caring about
how much control the government has over
what you can put into your body all
these different things so yes there is a
lot more political
turmoil but I think that that has
actually woken up a lot of people who
wouldn't have said things that sound
like what I say nowadays four years ago
they never would have dreamed of it but
now it's just their regular rhetoric
because they've become so used Shifting
the Overton window yes the chaos kind of
produced by a weak president forces
people to establish local order if you
don't it won't they won't do it for you
I think yeah that's part of it too I
mean that's not what I meant but that's
part of it too is the weakness of Joe
Biden uh people gravitate toward their
governor if their governor is you know
strong and I I I like that
decentralization I would rather people
you know invest in their own state
government instead of worrying about
what the federal government's doing I'm
with you on the wolf in sheep's clothing
being more dangerous than the uh fox in
the hen house except that the the the
the obvious fool here Joe I'm calling
you out because you surrender to the
Taliban the the absolute mishandling of
our military and the loss of life
accrued by Joe Biden
and he surrendered to China the fact
that he allowed the balloon to just
cross the the country without doing
anything and now it's coming out that
there that that they were monitoring and
there was uh radio frequencies that they
were monitoring the China I mean he's
neglected the National Security the
National Security of the U.S entirely so
it has caused people to step up at a
local level and take control of their
lives but whether or not we're better
off having a weak president I don't know
because that loss of life in Afghanistan
is absolute that's going to hang on I
just got to talk about Afghanistan real
quick because the problem with
Afghanistan is that we stayed too long
Joe by uh sorry Donald Trump made a deal
with the Taliban that we would be out of
Afghanistan I think it was May 1st of
2020 was that 2021 yeah 2021 yeah and
then Joe Biden came in and he was an
arrogant ass and he said no we are going
to leave on September 11th because I'm
not going to have Donald Trump's stupid
Afghanistan withdrawal plan so he stayed
an extra what four and a half months no
didn't get people out than the Taliban
that's not the pro that's not the
problem with with Afghanistan the
problem with that with with Afghanistan
was he got the combat troops out what
you do is you point guns at all the bad
guys and get your people out and leave
the guys with the guns pointed at the
bad guys on the ground and the guys with
the gun with the guns they leave last
everybody out and that was the problem
so it wasn't being killed on cars
outside the Air Force Base by Taliban he
abandoned Bagram Air Force Base yeah I
mean if you want to withdraw from
Afghanistan and I I agree like we should
not have been there we should have been
there at all yeah but the one thing you
do is you tell the local security
Partners this the Afghan forces hey go
set up security over the next two weeks
to lock down the Air Force Base to
secure these areas uh they needed to
make sure they had logistics for their
for the for their aircraft for the
helicopters for the for the Jets or
whatever they're using one of the
problems we heard was that there were
people Afghan Security Forces literally
flying at the time when Biden abandoned
the country and all of a sudden all
their Logistics get cut off and they
have no idea what's going on the Taliban
without communication there was no
Defense Force and so we learned in the
middle of the night they abandoned the
Air Force Base say nothing and locals
went in and started looting the place
they gave everything to the Taliban
that's why I called a surrender literal
you surrender equipment or items or
people well what Reid and Jose are
talking about is strategy which is the
way that you know Biden came in and
wanted to have the the exit on September
11th for a look but the major problem
with withdrawal from Afghanistan was
tactical it was the way that they
actually did it they didn't set security
to get the the
non-combatants out to get the get the
people that were helping the Americans
whether they be Afghans or whether they
be other other countries or whatever the
net of the U.S Nationals all the
civilians all the the you know whether
you like CIA or not get all the CIA
assets out get all the assets out and
then you take big army out then you take
the guys with the guns out and the guys
with the guns all Point guns at everyone
buddy and say no you're not doing
anything and then they they all get on a
plane and leave but you don't take the
security forces out first okay it was
the major problem was tactical I agree
with you on that like I mean there's no
disagreement that the civilians come out
first but when you make a deal with the
Taliban which is the most official
government in Afghanistan we will be
gone in May which is what Donald Trump
told them in 2020 yes and then Joe Biden
comes in and drags his feet it doesn't
get the people out of there and like you
said take the military out last be out
by May that's what he should have done
yes well I I argue that if you give your
enemy uh a date I'll be out by January
1st January 1st comes and you're like
you know I'm not ready This Is War dude
yeah you wait till I leave because we
have you we are at War I mean they're
lucky they're still alive the Americans
could have nuked the entire country if
they wanted to and we well they look at
it the same way though the Taliban if
you've made a deal with them like we're
going to be gone by this time and then
you're not I mean they feel the same way
that we feel about them attacking our
guys it's like look dude you said you
were going to be gone you're in our
country and that wasn't even your first
day I think we've given them we've kept
been jerking their chain for forever I
believe the setting state after day
after day there's at least multiple
other ones from what I recollect I'm not
as good it just ended up being like uh I
think it was actually September 1st when
we left it ended up being I'm all about
the horrendous why we're even there in
the first place it's insane get out as
soon as possible but it wasn't done
right no no disagreement I think it
would have been a crap show either way
to be honest I mean don't be wrong I
think there's definitely probably room
to say you know could it have been
handled better maybe Trump's plan was
better I don't know but at the end of
the day like I don't think like let's be
real the taliban's the Taliban and we
didn't really have anything set in place
no would we ever have something in place
to to resist this so it was going to be
a crap show no matter what it's just a
matter to what degree now I think like I
think the military I think the military
knows that there is a proper way to
withdraw forces from a hostile area I
think the military like they're I think
they're better ways probably yes well
yeah I mean I mean I don't think there's
going to be any situation that ends up
looking good you know well I mean I
don't know but you I don't know I think
that they they probably could have kept
I think they probably could have kept
things it's gonna come down a little bit
but I mean like you don't need bombs
going off and you don't need to take
your security Force out before you get
your your you also had Trump's generals
lying to him about the status of how
things were in those countries you know
you have a train wreck yeah I was saying
this the other night with the members of
Congress if we were able to get another
Trump term without the weights on his
legs with Russia gate and the other lies
and the manipulation of the nonsense I
think things would be would go
swimmingly it would be it would be
amazing what we would see I genuinely
believe Trump wanted a side of these
foreign Wars I genuinely believe he
wanted us to have no involvement as
World Police I I genuinely believe he
wants to cure our borders bring
factories back and start improving these
things you know I think like you guys
were saying he's a 90s Democrat or
whatever yeah but what you get with that
with him is
russiagate investigations lies
manipulations Ukraine gate impeachment
Scandal and so even with all of that
I've heard from so many people back in
2019 about how it was the best year of
their lives in terms of making money and
seeing their companies grow and getting
better jobs now we have Joe Biden and
everything's just bad I mean it's bad we
the the I talk about this local race
track the horse track they want to
reopen the restaurant so you can hang
out have a burger and watch the horses
run that sounds like an awesome time but
they can't find any workers we we tried
getting people to come out here and do
work on our HVAC and they just ghost us
it's crazy how how messed up it is right
now I wonder I wonder if you guys
listening at home are experiencing
similar things where like people just
don't want to work
and I I think what we were saying we
were hearing the other day from Byron
Donald's is that with the stimulus
package and the money that was being
given out pushed largely by democrats
you get demand at high but supply low
because nobody is working to produce
anything it's going to drive prices way
up oh yeah no disagreement there and
this isn't to excuse any of Biden's
policies Biden's policies have a hundred
percent made things way worse but we
were already living in a bubble when you
know after the 2008 crash you know
things started building up and then we
were living on low interest rates things
were artificially you know more popping
than they should have been there was
going to be something that pricked the
bubble eventually if I were Donald Trump
I personally wouldn't have wanted to get
reelected in the end of 2020 I would
have read the writing on the wall then
like it was things are going to suck
next year and the year after regardless
of who the president is definitely made
things worse but yeah it's the boom bus
Cycles just we print a bunch of money
the money gets artificially inflated
seems to be a better deal than it is and
we and we convince ourselves that's
great and so we keep on doing it keep on
doing it until eventually the floor
falls out and right back down again
these guys oh that's the vibe I hit with
Jim Cramer when he there's a quote where
he was like is the best year of Our
Lives or the best you know but I think
what happened is the the inflation
balloon had expanded to its capacity so
it's like this is the biggest the
balloon has ever been guys I don't I
don't think that the bubbles popped
yeah the air is coming out fast but I
don't I'm like it's like if you if
you're of the opinion that the the you
know the economy was overheated and they
printed too much money and things you
know are gonna get bad if you're of the
of that opinion things have not even
come close to how bad they're going to
correct because you're because the the
the bubble in the dollar has not gone
away me and serge were actually talking
about this before uh it was funny in the
the before show whatever thing he does
um actually my buddy Clint uh Clint uh
Clint Russell we talked about this
before and he has a theory that he
thinks likely probably the next 10 years
that China will probably collapse
monetarily in some form now that'll
likely cause some sort of deflation
pressure which will then boost us back
up and so then we get that juice that
like you know where everything's great
it's awesome but he said China China is
because you know the way they the way
they expand how we expand we expand
militarily they expand with money uh
because they're far more communist and
they've you know it exponential over
time it's building up so I mean it's
just a matter of it's the same idea with
the boom bust cycle over here but to a
greater degree so it's just a matter of
when does this pop I don't know I would
say likely I mean I don't know could
somehow it could be papered over
something else could happen but let's
say their money did bust that would
cause a deflationary pressure over here
to where we kind of sort of get sucked
back into a boom and if that happens
then what happens when we convince
ourself we're great all over again and
we're like oh no problem just keep on
going like we do and then the floor
comes again later and it's even lower
maybe uh I mean if that's the case then
you you're essentially everyone's got a
little bit of time to prepare or a
little more time yeah that's better but
you got to be mindful and look at from a
bigger picture so you understand that
you can still move to New Hampshire it's
not too late yeah so like are you saying
the US was spread out militarily kind of
like the British Empire with India for
instance and then India had a revolution
and Britain lost all that Revenue coming
out of India so would it be a Chinese
economic Revolution or like Chinese
companies are in Afghanistan but one day
those people will be like actually we
live here I just mean they're doing
they're inflating their money at a
higher uh how do I put this at a higher
rate than we are so they are they're
going like this whereas we're going like
this so they're more likely they're
going to Boom at some or Bust at some
point like this the money is not sound
with what they're doing like they you
can't just print money forever
eventually goes down that's why they
have whole ghost cities and stuff yeah
yeah I mean it's not just their money of
us also their architecture and
everything like if you look at the ghost
cities like he's talking they have the
homeless problem but they also have
these giant cities that nobody lives in
it's almost like communism is a bad form
of Economics I know they're a mixed
they're sort of like a mixed thing I
guess you know when World military
superpowers start to go bankrupt they
tend to look outside of their borders
for resources like the Nazis uh the
Germans when they were destroyed after
World War one they almost had you could
argue no choice but to invade foreign
countries for to repopulate or repurpose
like if they lose their pipelines but
with the Petro dollar we don't have to
worry about it the way past Empires had
to because people are forced to use our
currency to buy things so we just we
don't got to do anything we just point
guns and then say use our money or else
we just gotta Aid in a genocide in Yemen
so the Saudis will keep you know
printing dollars uh printing oil and
dollars Peter zeihan are you guys
familiar with his has pronounced his
last name he's brilliant guy who was on
Rogan a few weeks ago on Rogan that's so
funny of riding on his shoulders um but
he said that China would be gone in five
years I don't know what exactly he meant
yeah and and that we'd be it was almost
like I'm not hopeful I don't know what
to think about that because like I mean
the Soviet Union dissipated relatively
peacefully yeah they they broke up I
don't know that I'm not sure it was
relatively peacefully I mean there was
there was a lot of turmoil in preferable
just for how big it is it's preferable
to like an international War but I think
if you go to like the former Soviet
states that are no longer Soviet States
the 90s were real rough there are still
people in the Soviet in Russia that long
for the days of the Soviet Union because
they remember the 90s and it's the 90s
were really really really hard in
Eastern Europe and and the former Soviet
States and they don't look at Freedom
the way that we do because freedom for
them was full of corruption and a lot of
bad people that had influence in the in
the the the state before just started
taking things and saying well me and my
boys with the guns now own this Refinery
or whatever so it wasn't so peacefully
it just we didn't see the effects here
in the U.S of the break of the Soviet
Union so so clearly thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time